[Music]
all right
so if you're an american you know that
uh it's
voting season yes and uh politics are
in our faces if you read the news and
stuff it's crazy
and if you happen to not like trump and
if you also happen to not like what
biden is selling
then you have a new contender
please papa smurf papa smurf kanye
kanye's running yeah kanye west
announced on july 4th
that he will be running for president he
announced that years ago
yeah years ago yeah like is he serious
serious he's he's serious
so he's running for president in 2020
under a new
banner so it's not the democrat party
and it's not the republican party is it
the birthday party
it's the birthday party wait i was
joking
i was like oh he read it he read that's
tight no no i was joking
it says right here called the birthday
birthday party
no because i'm always joking about like
no one could hate on birthday parties
like if i had a political party it would
be called the dude you should join him
you guys are like
what the [ __ ] no oh that's crazy
republicans and [ __ ] the democrats i
heard you have my own party
he's a troll dude yeah it passed the
deadline to register and he
only forced some paperwork i think
there's like 12 states that
his name can't be on there so they have
to write him in but for the rest of
state
so is he delusional he does not realize
he's watching he's also i think he's a
joker
uh another bipolar episode right now
that's what his family says
that's what they're saying but i think
they're just marketing geniuses honestly
because they always create a big scandal
and like so kim kardashian's that's like
the worst thing to say
for a guy that's like just announced
running for president but then everyone
would look him up and like
what's he doing right now he has a new
album yeah does he have a new album
though yeah
new album new new sneakers it's called
happy birthday
to you and my marketing genius i'm not
saying his actions are correct i'm just
saying that they know how to get their
name
in people's mouths yeah
true that's what i mean well he's also
teaming up with another
recently he has gotten himself in the
the
the the what do you call it the tabloids
the tabloids as it is yes elon musk
is one of his advisors he tweeted you
have my full support right
yes and then and then he has like and it
says here obscure
vice presidential candidate when is this
mercury retrograde get a [ __ ] stop
this is
weird so are they gonna come out with
electrical shoes
is that why they'll walk for you sick
that'd be sick i
just wanna glide isn't this funny
because once trump became president i
think everyone was like well i could do
it now [ __ ] it
no i think it started with um reagan
no trump no schwarzenegger yes with
trump
reagan was like an actor then he became
president true so
but he was still a decent dude human
being well
i wouldn't say that i think he uh he's
he was good on camera and he wasn't like
charismatic
yeah he wasn't a bad boy no yeah he was
just still
like a clean-cut president you know like
yeah but now we have like social media
and stuff like that and you see like the
full size and people just
can say whatever and it hits everyone
and we realize that those like if
if ronald reagan was trying to be
president now compared to these guys he
would still
look ten times better than them that's
true yeah yeah
well we have we have history on our side
too it's looking back it
makes sense but then at the time i feel
like because if you watch back to the
future they'd make a joke about reagan
being president
oh and i feel like they're like he's an
actor no way [ __ ] weird that ronald
reagan's are president you the actor
yeah the actor yeah exactly yeah yeah
but yeah so
well let me ask you guys this i mean if
we saw trump as on the um on the tv
like what what was it the the not the
bachelor the princess apprentice right
and if someone told us like back to the
future style they go
he's going to be our president i would
be like
go back to the future [ __ ] you crazy
ass
i would never believe that [ __ ] i like
how you believe that they're from the
future
and they're telling you the truth is
like nah
go back to the future too
[Laughter]
and you see him like come in a spaceship
that just like appeared out of nowhere
he buys that he buys everything but
but the actual fact i get it you're from
the future but come on man
stop [ __ ] with me true well out of
all the celebrities then if not so trump
is
was a celebrity before being a
politician kanye's a celebrity
trying to be a politician now the rock
should be the politician
george clooney i was leaving
what's the platform the rock is gonna
definitely work i mean everyone loves
tick-tock
there you go he's a hard worker yeah he
he unifies
he's a uniform he gives like
presidential speeches all the time yeah
he's a positive motivational he's a
presidential [ __ ]
any and he would look good like with
when you see the un council you see this
big ass [ __ ] president and he's proud
yeah every speech starts off with like a
chain run and then he's doing dips at
the podium yeah [ __ ] yeah
i'm i'm voting for the rock time i feel
like the president like they have to be
like
one politically smart and everything but
they should be physically
like yes because
well wait like really earned it or is it
because
yeah he was like he's a black belt in
judo yeah it's part of like the russian
i know
but but i'm just saying because of his
title like who's gonna
like not give him a black belt no i
think he earned it before
oh like he has pictures of him
like riding on horses like half naked
just to show how strong he is and stuff
like why half naked how does that to
show off his backs like he's wearing
like
army fatigue it's not like it's not like
a muscle muscle but then it's like it's
like old man muscles
okay but it shows that he's like a
strong mofo though
i saw this one video of him that was
pretty dope where he went and like just
like they're basically
imagine they had to build like uh a
hospital and they're like oh we need 10
million dollars
so they give them that and then there's
like all this corruption that happens
people take money
and then they're asking for more money
so he goes and starts talking to them
and it was like
hundreds of millions of dollars and he's
basically like where's like the money
you guys said is gonna be done he was oh
yeah we need more we
do this and like now he's basically
basically being fed um
uh he's seeing all the corruption and
he's like you guys are getting
more money if if it's not fixed by this
time it's gonna be problems and if i
have to come back here it's gonna be
serious problems and like you see the
guys that are like
in the full corruption being like oh
that basically means i'm gonna get
killed if i don't
actually start using the money properly
i was like that's what we need
because here it's like yeah but then he
also does the same [ __ ] like remember
when the olympics happen he's like oh i
got a buddy who's gonna build the
olympic stuff
well that's what we do too yeah but then
but it was way worse because then they
made it super unsafe super cheap but
they
paid like 10 times the price that's what
i expected the money from if i
went to olympics in russia though that's
why that's why half of the
you expect corruption in russia that's
why a lot of the american like athletes
were like oh we're not going to run that
course so a lot of people just turned it
down yeah
we just hide it here from our world you
do hide it very well
yeah you said george clooney where would
george clinton run on uh
just because i was like um last time we
talked i was saying george clooney was
way better looking than uh
he's just looking i want a good looking
president i don't know man
the rock's pretty up i think the rock
can pull way more votes
his following is huge and across every
background too
doesn't matter do you think it's
important a president have social media
presence then
no no i'm scared it's bad the game's
changed though
game has changed it's bad but you need
it if you don't have it nobody knows who
you are and you don't know
contemporary culture if you don't use
social media i know but
the way that [ __ ] trump uses this
[ __ ] i'm just like can someone take his
[ __ ]
accounts away what about i mean yang did
a great job using
because everyone only pays attention to
people that are like talking [ __ ] or
causing he also got snubbed by the
democratic uh national community so like
why is biden our candidate exactly
that's what people should be asking
yeah because he is just not all there
what happened to hillary clinton i mean
he just got she's that outcome she's not
running no no
i think she she's like might be going to
jail or something
who hilarious miss hillary yeah right
for emails
she might be going to jail to see
someone but yeah that's probably
it so anyways i'm back to kanye
so he's uh you know how he's he's rep
the the maga hat
and uh he's been buddy buddies with
trump so apparently with his move into
the
presidential candidate category he is no
longer going to support trump
and i quote i am taking off the red hat
you know who would have been great
though is uh tulsi gabbard
i [ __ ] loved her she would have been
because i think andrew is too pragmatic
to the point where
people don't understand him he's just
too small it sounds
yeah and he's asian and i'm not sure if
america is ready for an asian president
because they'll think oh
chinese man oh chinese virus oh yeah
[ __ ] that enemy
like they're that stupid that's what
that was a very poor timed
thing to kind of start camping what's
funny though it's like he was like oh
we're trying to give say like thousand
dollars a month to people or whatever
yeah and people like that's [ __ ]
stupid and then now everyone's like
where's my where's my stimulus
let andrew yang run again in four years
i feel like he was the happiest time
it's funny because people interview
andrew yang now and they're like that
stimulus check
that was a good idea huh that's a great
idea
he was like i try to tell you guys i
think that poor dude
is kind of like i try to tell you and
then
the public is just so [ __ ] dumb that
they don't get it yet
they're just not ready to receive this
information he's just two light years
ahead
and then he's just gonna live his whole
president life just being like i try to
tell you guys
eventually i think you're running it i
think he will yeah i hope so he's young
too i feel like he has a lot of legs
underneath
this kind of feels like his initial like
his name's in the public now so now when
he comes back again everyone's like oh i
know that guy yeah who is frank
was a friend of mine who's the guy that
was like all about the
global war warming and stuff al gore al
gore
what was he running for right he was
resident he was running for president i
want to know
he got beat by uh bush yeah yeah
i want to see if he won what would
happen i don't think anything so
uh during the clinton administration the
democratic party
switched to just representing
corporations just like the republican
party
like it used to be the party of the
people and they're still campaigning on
that but have you heard of like
limousine liberals like hillary gets
like 2 300 grand every time she speaks
all these top-level democratic people
that claim they're for the people
they live in beverly hills and all these
really nice neighborhoods
and they're just like yeah i'm here for
the protesters and when the protesters
come into their neighborhood they call
the police
like they're not real [ __ ] like i
mean
guards with them and then they're like
take away people's guns the main term
they use for democrats now is the big
tent party
it's not what does that mean because it
houses everybody like
more than republicans is a little bit
more narrow democrats you have the super
progressives you have the moderates
you have like aoc who won't take any big
donations period bernie does the same
thing
yeah yeah so it's just so wide now that
it's like it's not a singular view yeah
and for me
i like progressives and i like the new
uh
the new new the new new that they're
coming in they're not corrupted by
uh corporations so i only see it as old
guard and new that's probably why
they're not winning though
yeah that's why it's so divided that
they're like they're not taking those
bribes or whatever and yeah so they get
ousted they get ousted
but those companies are like no we're
paying you so you can have like a good
end with us
or we have a good idea with you that's
why buy it in one cause he'll keep the
status quo
he knows the game he's a career
politician like he
and these career politicians man they
flip flop like a
[ __ ] dude right now he's talking
about how we have to protect
like all the inner cities this and that
but there's
video of him talking to congress talking
about the threat
of super predators which they called the
young black males back then
when he was going the high um anti-crime
laws right
back in the day he was like we need to
go we need to control them they're just
[ __ ] desolate whatever whatever
talking all this mad [ __ ] about the
inner cities
and then now he's out there just doing
what's
popular he's a [ __ ] flip-flopper he's
not for the people but how do you feel
about flip-floppers or people who just
are willing to listen to other people
because then he just got out of a huge
meeting recently with like bernie and
all of the big progressives
so if all of a sudden he adopts some of
their ideas because he wants to
compromise are you gonna be like he
flip-flopped or you can be like oh cool
i mean if he's genuinely
changing policies that's not a flip-flop
move
to me a career politician says and does
lip service
to do what's popular but they don't vote
consistently to their ideals
so most people vote consistently to the
ideals
of uh or what they should be doing like
ron paul or
some career politicians that's been
around they stay
there's some core values that people
have in politics right if you're gonna
represent the republican party or
whatever
let's say you you you want to have
us back on the gold standard or whatever
right so you fight for that or you're
fighting for
uh gun rights or whatever you don't
drastically keep changing based off of
what is the most
popular thing in the moment which biden
does and hillary does
that's true yeah you know who doesn't
chase the popular [ __ ]
it's kanye west kanye west said to say
that the black vote is democratic it's a
form of racism and white supremacy
so he's addressed the fact that by doing
what he wants to do right now
if it goes through because i'm actually
not aware of whether or not the window
is closed for him
but he does he did address the fact that
he will be siphoning off black votes
from the democratic nominee from biden
because biden has a big platform for you
so it's basically going to make trump
win
for sure yes yeah there's the way of
looking
want is to win so bad if your only
choice is trump
yeah i want kanye to win a thousand
percent
because i think like i
really don't like biden that'll be tight
if he rewrites the
national anthem oh it's all bumping
that'd be sick because the national
anthem has come under scrutiny too
for having you know a certain time he
writes a new one that we all really like
and instead of going like this you get
to like yeah the national anthem
is when i hear it i'm like oh say
can you yeah why do they have to like be
boring that's what i'm saying they're
picturing
you like beyonce though it's it's good
i think back then they would be like oh
this hits the spot
but now it's like hmm it's an oldie
not a goodie not a good every time every
ten years a new song
[Music]
you